[Musik]
ich bin vom dienstag opera auf dem weg
zum wachtmeister und im zivilen leben
junger pilot
[Musik]
ich habe grundwehrdienst absolviert habt
dann abgerüstet und dann habe ich mich
in vielen okay es wäre doch eine gute
alternative oder eine option
und seitdem bin ich aktiv dabei
also die modulare ausbildung hat
besonders eben für berufstätige den
vorteil dass diese blöcke mit eigentlich
fast jeden dienstgeber irgendwie
vereinbar sind
ich muss es nicht diese vier bzw mit den
vier modulen zwei module also in sechs
module in summe muss ich nicht in einem
jahr schaffen sondern ich habe vier
jahre in zeit diese brücke hinter mir zu
bringen was glaube ich fast jeden
eigentlich irgendwie machbar ist
beruflich und familiär
[Musik]
es gibt unzählige erlebnisse und
ereignisse von denen glaube ich jeder
medizin kamerad berichten kann
in der miliz gibt ist eine tolle
kameradschaft und dann ein auch schon in
diesem kurs gestern zum beispiel beim
gefälschtes dienst hatten wir eine sehr
lehrreiche zeit aber auch eine sehr
unterhaltsame zurück
[Musik]
als er sich besonders in der miliz die
vielfalt dass alle altersgruppen
vertreten sind das die menschen
herkommen kameradschaftlich miteinander
sitzen sich gegenseitig ergänzen und das
beste einfach auf einen einsatz machen
teil der miliz zu sein bedeutet für mich
einzigartige kameradschaft und einsatz
für österreich
[Musik]
im schnitt bedeutet für mich herzblut
und genauso gut freundschaft über alle
grenzen hinweg
[Musik]